welcome to this video playing just kit
and just kids from the US have never
getting before the first game when we
play a do go something hybrid let's give
it some independent flavor by by playing
it with f5 interesting way okay grab
here and then g6
maybe g6 mmm it looks like white might
manage to play four which is not so
great maybe I can play F one F or F one
hmm then five problem yeah anyway this
is the Dutch opening in a way another
move order different move order but in
the Dutch opening you shouldn't fear to
and some murky positions happens time
and time again
yeah the critical move now must be
really if I've okay didn't do that
so I get to play e5 and I'm glad that
I'm managed that I'm getting my bishop
in the game yeah yeah this is possible
but what the night is stop doing much on
b3 I can I have a good square on his
seven for the Queen
hmm yeah maybe I can even use the
default square here with bishops uniform
and it's quite nice
I usually usually played 45 after that
I'm pretty sure that I had problems so
to define I probably will sacrifice the
exchange mmm
maybe I should should start after
chicken and then 94 Queen f2 94 is also
quite awkward
Queen f2 94 m and now who why is he
going green f2 there's an idea for and
oh this is this is really bad now it's
really bad yeah again 94 looks looks
rather strong I can take it with the
night over the bishop though they don't
really have a direct win against that
okay so I so I should probably just move
the Knight to d7 or or where
taking here Quinn checks not sure that
I'm winning 95 maybe
okay let's just double on the F farm
he's got Bishop g4 Jim this really this
really wasn't a good one far not
forcefully enough very stupid maybe
he'll just repeat and now I should think
again how to how to win him there isn't
any tactic here night 93 yes some
somebody promise I take here Queen takes
there is no tactic in hard to believe
I don't I don't see a tactic here that
that wins the game immediately and he's
threatening 93 Queen back 95 amazing
that's probably really embarrassing
because there are a couple of a couple
of wins in there but okay now I'm
threatening to take and 95 check I taken
all night if 195 immediately then look
here but okay there is a pin down
okay let's secure this if I take now
here still not winning on takes Queen
takes and nothing great really
remarkable
yeah it's always nice with the knight on
d4 word I really have one of my really
blind days we head don't see the don't
see the forced win and there is one
there is not much doubt about that or at
least there was a fast when this is this
I'm very sure of Jack if he gives a
check on everyone I have a good spot on
e7 the knight is catching the critical
entry squares I want to have as many
pawns on light squares a special morning
so that now the Queen's red is winning
easily with the knight coming to before
Chang the night comes to be for and win
say to this is why a3 was was quite good
I think yeah but still I mean them they
must have been a maid or material win
really weird
yeah well not not Viera sometimes have
those games where I really feel like I'm
totally totally stupid I'm not promoting
him immediately
stretch him hmm
I don't really need you need to do that
how do I mean how do I actually win this
maybe still g5 win g3 somehow there's
some good way to win g3 hmm probably
here I'm taking far too much time you
can start with this actually and
threaten a tomb this is this is quite
good actually this this was winning all
the time I didn't see it before
now we cannot take because a2 promotes
and this is really the threat now I'm
just promoting we atactic check check
check check check
yeah okay I just checked linking on
preemies yeah I'm really amazed that I
didn't see you when probably I'm just
really blind
there was one very critical spot we
could have played before he fired which
was very likely good for white I thought
if I VM and the computer's not so
enthusiastic yeah maybe the computer is
right it's possible the stockfish a
gives this kind of position with 95
coming as okay maybe it is not very much
used to this type of position gives
white only 0.4 yeah maybe it wasn't like
blowing out of the water is too strong
okay so this if he plays this I always
have night to h5 this idea they get the
Knight to f4 with good play
okay this and around him so I have a
really great position maybe I'm taking
wasn't really precise but okay it looks
it looks really ugly whelming okay I
could I could check I could play this
first of course I was a bit irritated by
the possibility of rook g4 take sandy
fire but it's really not nothing special
I am just good for black yeah
okay I played this first at the computer
gives rook 88 as the best move okay well
not this so we repeat it now I saw it
no Queen b6 okay but that does not
really seem to be a win just what I play
this is okay amazing I was pretty sure
there was something something really
overwhelming
hmm and this seems to be imprecise g6
it's given by the computer with Queen g5
and h5h for coming mmm yeah it's it's of
course good in any case I have this
fantastic night against the
stupid-looking bishop okay I was playing
this in a more technical so Jack TM b3
yeah he absolutely must avoid the Queen
trade that's absolutely impossible to
allow after this it's a check it is a
direct win v6 also was posed b6 was
stronger of course because it b6 and
taking on b3 okay but as I just saw that
it's winning when I come to come to
before and here I can win with 93 all
the time as didn't see it I was playing
this stuff on the kingside first because
my original idea to win was something
like this check here and then eat all
the pawns this is why I had pushed the
pawns to a 2g phone h5 because I wanted
to win g3 at the end but then I saw that
this wins as well but then I saw that
this actually promotes the pawn could
have been done earlier of course okay
thanks for watching